on hey what's going on it's bill burn
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday March 4th 2019 what's going
on our yeah I know I'm really late I'm
really late but yesterday was the first
taping my next special at Royal Albert
Hall and tonight is the next one so
yesterday I had a bunch of stuff I had
to do for like the intro with a special
and all of that type of stuff so it went
great last night had an awesome time and
I never taped a special where I always
just did like two shows one night done
I've never done like a show and then
waited a whole day and then do another
show so I'm just looking tonight like I
could not have been more thrilled with
how it went last night did not have any
of this stupid torture that happens
afterwards were you just like oh god I
want it I do there's a lot of I didn't
say that is anybody gonna like me after
this I didn't do any of that [ __ ] I was
just like alright it missed something
here missed who gives a [ __ ] right yeah
it's fine I don't give a [ __ ] it's it's
all gonna be good so tonight I'm just
gonna go out and have a good time and as
excited as I was to record this special
I after last night I kind of felt a
little bit of sadness of like I'm really
gonna miss these jokes I've never had
that feeling before but I know the next
ones are coming or whatever but it's
kind of hitting me here if if I'm doing
this like wow this is kind of the end of
the run for these jokes you know and
then I just move on like Bill Bixby
right at the end of the Hulk just walk
away from the act and the smartest thing
I did was I already did a gig at Royal
Albert Hall
[ __ ] sake somebody else just coming
hang on hang on hang on hang on sorry
hey hit pause if I can ring the doorbell
and then rings it again like the [ __ ]
hotels on fire oh sorry to disturb you
just want to know if you need anything
in the minibar no I'm good thank you
she's really assuming I'm not [ __ ]
here two [ __ ] rings what if I was
sitting here with my [ __ ] balls
hanging and
you're gonna ring it that fast and then
you walk in and then let me guess I'm in
trouble right is it true you had your
balls out sir well yes I was in the shut
up there was a woman knocking on that
door you should have realized at any
second someone could come walk again by
the way is that John Wayne stuff the
dumbest thing what is this thing now
we're we're just gonna dig up dead
people and did you see what they said in
1964 well I am I imagine nothing good
the [ __ ] got this documentary coming
out about Michael Jackson it's just like
the guys dead like so I don't understand
like what the [ __ ] would dig every other
day now somebody dead somebody's got to
come along and [ __ ] dig them up and
be a you know they you know I don't know
how much you enjoy this music if you
know that the person did this why do
they only do it to famous people can all
of us dig up our grandparents and be
like yeah remember when you said that
[Laughter]
all of these [ __ ] it I just don't I
do not [ __ ] get it I don't [ __ ]
get it can you believe this [ __ ] guy
who was born in 1907 sounded like a guy
who was born in 1907 yes yes I can't
whose grandparents don't go out and say
crazy [ __ ] that's the new [ __ ] thing
unearthed unearthed a [ __ ] interview
from 40 50 years ago and then line it up
with today's you know what's right in
you don't have to go back that far go
back in somebody's Twitter history
remember when you said this yeah no no
remember when we were all saying that
that's what you're supposed to know you
know what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] what now
just I just wanted to see some [ __ ]
[ __ ]
hello
you have what
miss who I don't know who that is all
right bye
I have miss Simmi
mr. Kimmy I don't know [ __ ] that is
anyways Jesus Christ yeah that's like
the new [ __ ] thing the new [ __ ]
thing is to go back in time and just
look up a yak or egg evidently Truman
Capote was he wasn't in his [ __ ]
Truman as we thought he was just think
about someone just before all of the
[ __ ] jokes I literally saw somebody
get interviewed the other day and they
were talking about the office the
American version and they asked could
you make that today and ah no no we we
could never do that we go most of those
jokes wouldn't work today that was 10
[ __ ] years ago
all right so Jesus Christ enough with
the [ __ ] shock and awe that you're
gonna dig up somebody who died 40
[ __ ] years ago and they said
something surprising it's like if you
were born in 1907 and so many
interviewed you 40 years ago you you
would not want that interview to be made
[ __ ] public
you wouldn't anyways what [ __ ] world
do we live in that the the office is now
considered too edgy for television
oh Jesus you could never do it was the
most absurd [ __ ] shows you ever saw
in your life I don't know but that's
where we are because that's where we are
because eight percent of the [ __ ] it
that's my roughly as far as I can tell
the people that I talk to everybody else
is just like dude what is the big
[ __ ] deal
yeah you know what's [ __ ] hilarious
someday you're gonna sound like your
[ __ ] grand parents someday you're
gonna be in your [ __ ] 70s and
something you said in your 40s it's
gonna sound [ __ ] ridiculous like
nobody's like it's nobody's allowed to
like I don't know I don't I didn't
[ __ ] and I don't understand all of
these [ __ ] people that are going on
social media doing this it's just I was
really what about you I think that
anybody gave a [ __ ] about you you know
[ __ ] and went back into your [ __ ]
life they can't find somebody to say
that you said something that did
something it's called being a human
being Jesus [ __ ] Christ I told you
that [ __ ] when I was in Scotland that
woman left that wrote that [ __ ]
article was talking about commemorative
statues and she's like nothing makes my
heart sink like when I hear they're
gonna put up a commemorative statue it's
like nothing [ __ ] a genocide child
pornography nothing quite makes you
[ __ ] heart drop like the making of a
commemorative statue anyways can you
believe Christopher Columbus was
actually a [ __ ] [ __ ] new evidence
shows it's just like where was that new
evidence what was it just sitting on
somebody's desk for [ __ ] 48 years
he's a fan al these [ __ ] people
compared to what somebody in 2019 yeah I
would like to think that people learn
how to treat other people better each
year so what we're supposed to be doing
you know what I mean if you go back and
watch an episode of solid gold there's a
lot of people dance and today that on
that date that would get laughed out of
the [ __ ] club and that was the peak
of dancing back then but it progressed
and now all those moves that were
unbelievable and now kind of basic
that's what happens it just got it you
know did you believe the guy that won
the Indy 500 and 1955 wouldn't even have
qualified for the race in 2019 I don't
think this guy's a champion I think they
need to rethink that championship so
I've been where he was probably going on
at 40 miles an hour I mean the [ __ ]
pace car today goes faster than that
I don't know and it's just it's alright
if does that do anything does it really
do anything to say hey this guy who's
been dead for 40 years is is actually
this now so what am I supposed to do now
go back and look at this person sports
career or their [ __ ] movie career and
look at them differently somehow and
then sit there and look at myself like
I'm this great [ __ ] person just
because I had the luxury of being born
when I was born and then be so [ __ ]
full of myself that I'm not looking at
this guy being like well wait a min
someday I'm gonna be dead 40 years and
then people go back and see the things
that I said and am I gonna like I'm
gonna survive that all right bill I
think you made your point
all right you know a lot of people think
Abe Lincoln's a good guy apparently new
evidence shows he went to a [ __ ]
Sadie Hawkins dance and he evidently he
was [ __ ] quite rude to his date that
night four score hashtag four score and
seven beers ago drink much Abe I don't
know anyways whatever so I got one more
one more [ __ ] night see this is what I
want to open with tonight this is what I
want to talk about and get this out of
my [ __ ] system but I had to [ __ ]
document my jokes tonight so I want to
thank everybody that came out in
Manchester Glasgow and Birmingham I had
a great time and found out that I was
not dehydrated I actually had a little
bit of a stomach virus I can't believe
it with this high quality food that I've
been eating here for the last [ __ ]
ten days you know easy oh my god I just
don't know if I'm just gonna have to be
going to the wrong places but what they
do do with cheeseburger over here it's
just like as an American and it's it's
offensive I feel like it's it's a one of
our signature dishes
what we added to the International
culinary [ __ ] whatever Frank sorry
let's try to be eloquent there for them
to just [ __ ] make it the way that
they make it I'm not telling you it's
just it's just something there's just
something wrong about it
but I keep ordering them in hopes it's
almost going to get it right
but anyways yet turned out I have a I
had like a stomach virus now I think I'm
past it so I can give my all to my
[ __ ] [ __ ] jokes tonight
rest in peace Luke Perry Jesus Christ
52 [ __ ] years old with kids that's a
scary one man and the guy weighed like a
hundred and thirty pounds it felt you
know so now I'm on the internet I'm not
trying to [ __ ] you know early signs
of a stroke and how you can screen for
and there you can do this to screen for
it but don't do it too many times cuz
the scan isn't good for you and it's
just like so they had the all these
lists here like the top causes this is
for all old men like me alright here we
go top causes for stroke all right here
we go come on hotel all right is
hypertension high blood pressure I was
psyched when the doctor came and took my
blood pressure said I have the blood
pressure of a 25 year old he goes do you
work out a lot and I said I do work out
a lot high cholesterol I don't have that
diabetes I don't have that central
obesity that means having a belly I
don't have that smoking I do that so
that's the one I got to get out because
I'm not living for myself anymore living
for the kid oh so and I've come to this
this this realization of not my boozing
I finally figured it out I figured out
what kind of drinking drinker I am
why it's gone off the rails while of a
sudden I became this guy that needed to
take breaks and yeah the big thing that
I do I [ __ ] to the house all right
and if I can give anybody any young man
young woman out there [ __ ] a young
[ __ ] transfer and humanoid whatever
the [ __ ] you supposed to say one of
those TR words all right yeah listen to
this little clip in 40 years okay and
we'll see if they take it down my
[ __ ] monument at the innovators of
podcasting and the filthy wing at the
podcast Museum right see if they don't
want to take down my [ __ ] golden
statute with the [ __ ] orange leaflet
over my balls you don't want to bring
your vices home with you okay you want
to have to go out and get them all right
so I the where I [ __ ] up is I ended up
having a booze collection at home and
because I was buying some higher-end
stuff you start to think oh I'm like a
collector I'm a connoisseur no dude
you're a [ __ ] booze hound so I'm just
gradually just given bottles away I got
some Pappy Van Winkle I'm not givin that
away you know but I have some a couple
nicer bottles of things that cost me
whatever 80 100 bucks or whatever but
like to be a I saw my kids see me
drinking okay obviously my kid can
listen to the podcast know what I was
but like I saw I don't want to be doing
that I don't be smoking cigars in front
of her I don't be drinking [ __ ] booze
none of that [ __ ] she asked me about it
I'll tell her what I did
I'll be honest with there and then tell
how how [ __ ] stupid it was how much
time I wasted and all that type of [ __ ]
you know I did have a good time you know
whatever but anyways I just say I just
don't think it's a good look you'd be
sitting at home [ __ ] booze and not
that I've ever done that in front of her
I wait till she goes to sleep but
there's been nights where I'm just like
wow dude I am like like you
rolling the dice here cuz god forbid I'm
down here legally [ __ ] hammered and
what if my wife had some sort of medical
issue now I'm drunk I got to get my kid
and my wife now I have what do I do here
I got a [ __ ] call an uber and all
this [ __ ] cuz I'm too drunk to drive or
Eve I just call the [ __ ] ambulance
I'm gonna be standing there [ __ ]
hammered if somebody's just not a good
look that's not that's not something a
dad does
we're not the dad that I want to be so
I'm getting the [ __ ] out of my house
I've decided I'm taking the year off and
then next year I'll see what I want to
do but if there's anything that I want
to do I'm gonna have to go out and go
get it
and that goes for the cigars too I'm
going to drastically cut that down and I
don't know but then I I remember hearing
this quote that said beware the man with
no vice or something like that man with
no vice saying let's see what it is what
is this thing
show me a man here we go show me a man
without vice and where is it show me a
man without vice and I'll show you one
without virtue now you know that doesn't
that just sound like some dumb [ __ ] a
drunk would say at a bar wait he doesn't
Jays [ __ ] doing something for man
let's see something here vices Vice
quotes I actually I don't understand
that it's like so if you live like a
vice las' life then you have no virtue
what is it virtue what is the actual
definition so unvirtuous I am behaviors
showing high moral standards so if you
don't have any low moral standards you
won't have any high moral standards so
if you're not [ __ ] blowings a couple
of rails that means you're not gonna
help a [ __ ] old lady across the street
why can't you be the guy who's not doing
blow not
boozing eating you know in a healthy way
and being a family man and also be a
good person I don't understand that you
know is it because if you meet somebody
that's strong enough is this just
insecurity by [ __ ] people that have
vices because I have me honestly thereby
if I can if I can get rid of I don't
booze and I didn't smoke cigars I think
that's it that Matt's what I do I drink
and smoke so now I'm not drinking since
I've been over here I've had one cigar
you know I barely smoke if I get rid of
that you know then what Jesus Christ
well then the bill you have the most
boring [ __ ] podcast in the history of
podcasting I guess I don't know I I got
a I'll figure it out though but I I
don't want to be this guy just like you
know I never have a drink or I never
have a cigar I just got to get it out of
my [ __ ] house all right I feel like
invited a vampire and you know like I'm
in The Lost Boys except with booze and
cigars so what do I'll do that then I'll
just sit there and judge my wife every
time she has a rose a nice nice example
that you're setting I got to be honest
with you
London I'm loving it you know I was
never really lund of Gaia was more Paris
guy I don't know what happened now I'm
starting to like London a little better
you know despite the [ __ ] food Jesus
Christ Jesus Christ did you know the
amount of places that they conquered
with all these spices you know I always
heard that they brought him back God
knows they're not [ __ ] use them it
has to be I don't know where to go you
know they got too many [ __ ]
celebrities out here all the Spice Girls
the Spice Girls right where do they eat
there's no way they put up with this
food there's no way I know last time I
came here I went to this Indian
restaurant that was [ __ ] unbelievable
and I also went to the ivy the other
night I had the best shepherd's pie I've
ever had
so it hasn't been all bad but I'll just
tell you everything else I've gone two
minutes it's like comedy club green room
bad alright but we get it you don't like
the [ __ ] food I'm sorry so what's
going on in the world of America I miss
the good ol USA let's see what when I
want to go to search USA news let's see
what happens
President Donald Trump serves fast food
to another title team yeah this is how
broke we are after [ __ ] these wars
why does he keep doing that does he do
this to anybody else
let's see president Donald Trump serves
fast food to another title team North
Dakota State another championship
football team well you know what this is
North Dakota State and there's a lot of
white guys on there he's still giving
him fast food dude I'd love to eat
McDonald's in the White House it's kind
of [ __ ] cool Trump welcomed the
Football Championship Subdivision
champions the North Dakota State bison
you get him some bison burgers here to
the White House on Monday and according
to a pool report he served them a
lunchtime spread at Big Mac chick-fil-a
sandwiches and french fries among other
fast food items Trump served a similar
meal to the Clemson Tigers while they
visited the White House in January
according to the pool report Trump told
the Bisons that he couldn't serve them a
meal prepared by the chef but I know you
people several players laughed oh that
he could have served them a meal
prepared by the chef's but I know you
people several players left according to
the pool report Trump said in January
that he personally paid for Clemson's
White House feast the feast now because
it's visit came in the middle of a
partial government shutdown is this it
maybe it's just him trying to be cool
you know did he go to college the Trump
even go to college
it's amazing how little I know about
this guy Donald Trump let's see what the
[ __ ] he went
he probably went to college where his
dad went to college and I thought
there's a legacy here he was one of the
greatest students ever of this
university and of course this isn't
gonna show up I have no idea all right
let me get to the let me read a little
bit advertising as this [ __ ] thing
comes together here all right oh here we
go there we go here we go honey you ever
want to buy something online only to
find out later you missed a discount
honey
is a free browser add-on that finds me
the best deals online the app magically
auto-replies the best deal to my cart at
checkout oh honey
finds discounts and coupons across
37,000 sites
Amazon Sephora Best Buy Nordstrom and
more shop like normal honey handles the
rest honey has saved it's ten million
members an average of 28 dollars and 61
cents overall or also it's it's saved
280 million 660 $1,000 I don't [ __ ]
honey members honey members have already
saved more than eight hundred million
dollars there you go thank you for
helping me out there well it doesn't
make sense ten million members let's say
oh my god with the [ __ ] with the
[ __ ] goddamn [ __ ] Jesus Christ
hang on a second
yeah but I'm just recording something
I'll do it yeah yep all right thank you
hey just Christ you just can't get the
[ __ ] food out of here fast now they
wanna get rid of the evidence all right
I swear to God nobody's knocked or
phoned the whole [ __ ] time the second
I turn on the recorder just seeing this
does the rug feel okay under your feet
sir where was a honey
honey members have already saved 800
more than 800 million dollars not bad
for something that's completely free and
takes just two clicks to install this is
[ __ ] free honey has over 100,000
five-star reviews on Google Chrome on
the Google Chrome store
Time magazine calls honey basically free
money look there's no reason to use
honey not to use honey it's free to use
and easy to install on your computer and
just two clicks so shop with confidence
get honey for free at join honey calm /
/ that's join honey dot-com / / be you
are our honey the smart shopping
assistant that saves you time and money
when you're shopping online oh look
everybody it's hims
him sixty-six percent of men start to
lose their hair by the age of 35
hey once you've noticed thinning hair it
can be too late
is that hairline slow he's starting to
move backwards any bald spots yet is
your dick still working the best way to
prevent more hair loss is to do
something about it while you still have
some it's time to get a handle on those
precious locks I asked you do you want a
bald spot to pop up on your hair or your
hairline to recede or do you want to do
something about it first why why did
guys turn to weird solutions or nothing
at all well hey maybe I just accepted it
why do you have to pick on me hims why
do they do that do this when they can
turn to medicine and science well a lot
of them had bad [ __ ] side-effects you
know early on hey man I'm just a podcast
listener I don't need to be attacked
here all right solution for hims calm a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
sexual wellness for four men thanks to
science baldness can be optional hims is
how weird am I gonna look when I get
older because everybody's gonna opt for
this [ __ ] they're just gonna get him to
keep their [ __ ] hair then kids right
on when I'm 60 kids will start
whispering
with that man did he used to be the
strong man at the circus why do guys to
Toco though for hims okay thanks to
science baldness can be an option hims
is helping guys be the best version of
themselves with licensed physicians and
fda-approved products to help treat hair
loss prescription solutions backed by
science hims was created by guys who
know by a guy who knows some men's
health conversations are easier online
than in person
might well dude you're going bald
everyone can see it I'm gonna try and
hide it my listeners can get started
with hims complete hair kit for just
five dollars right now while supplies
last and subject to doctor's approval
restrictions apply see website for full
details go to for hims hims calm / bird
that's fo r hims calm / bar for hims
calm
/ / alright Oh everybody look LegalZoom
LegalZoom five business five things
business owners can count on from
LegalZoom numero uno reliability over
two million people have used Legal Zoom
to start their businesses LLC's s corpse
nonprofits DBAs and more you can use
Legal Zoom to get started the right way
number two numero dos the experience I'm
counting right now in three different
languages if you're not keeping up
they've been helping all types of
business owners for over 17 years you
can count on Legal Zoom to help with all
the details numero uno dos tres numero
tres dirt y one two tree helpful support
they have the right people standing by
ready for your questions all based in
the US Quatro cat the Legal Zoom legal
Zuma's isn't a law firm but they have a
network of independent attorneys
licensed in all 50 states can I say
fifty in all
the language sangbong 50 I don't know
how to say in Latino whatever [ __ ] I'm
supposed to say in in Latin Spanish we
don't speak Spanish I didn't get the
[ __ ] book all right sorry all they
did was teach me about the pilgrims they
can route review contracts with
employment law with employment law
saying I came to retake and advise you
on many of the hurdles that pop up when
you're running a business and finally
number five
uno dos tres cuatro Cinco sank five no
surprises LegalZoom provides complete
transparency transparency with upfront
pricing customer reviews and a
satisfaction guarantee check out Legal
Zoom today to see how they can make life
better for you and your business and
don't forget to enter BER at checkout to
save even more Legal Zoom where life
meets legal legalzoom.com all right who
else we got here Oh policy genius policy
Jeanne Ellen I got oh this is the last
one thank Christ
all right policy genius getting life
insurance can feel like assembling the
world's worst jigsaw puzzle
how old was somebody who [ __ ] wrote
this copy getting life insurance can
feel like starting an old [ __ ] crank
start forward no matter how much you
blow the horn
you can feel like biting down on a bow
and arrow while someone digs a slug out
of your calf it's confusing it takes
forever and when you're finally done it
doesn't even look cool but if you have a
mortgage kids or anyone who's depending
on your income
it's a puzzle you need to solve and
policy genius can help you do it policy
genius is the easy way to get life
insurance it's just two minutes in just
two minutes you can compare quotes from
top insurers to find the best policy for
you when you apply online
the advisors at policy genius will
handle all the red tape they'll even
negotiate your rate with the insurance
company no Commission sales agents no
hidden fees just helpful advice in
personalized services and policy genius
doesn't make life insurance easy doesn't
just make life insurance easy they also
make it easy find the right home
insurance your auto insurance or
disability insurance they're your
one-stop-shop for financial protection
so if you find life insurance puzzling
head to policy genius calm in two
minutes you can prepare quotes find the
right policy and save up to 40% doing it
policy genius the easy way to compare
and buy life insurance all right and
with that let's see if Donald Trump's
Wikipedia page came up it did he was
born June 14th
Gemini 1946 his current president was
born and raised in New York borough of
Queens he got an economics degree from
the Wharton School that's a good one you
know I know that's a good ones I've
never really heard of it which means
that's a high end one it was not on my
radar to be applied to he was appointed
president of his family's real estate
business in 1971 look at that he was
only 25 years old and he took on that
level of responsibility everybody else
gets to go out to a [ __ ] bar and
drink you know sing some karaoke and he
had to take over the family's real
estate business see everybody thinks
these rich kids have it easy
you know you poor kids have no idea how
lucky you are to be 25 and none at the
pressures of a real estate company that
take over the company built a renovated
sky crepe skyscrapers the hotels casinos
and golf courses Trump later stated
various site started various side
ventures including licensing his name
for real estate and consumer products
yeah that's the genius that's why when
everybody's like given the finger to a
Trump Hotel it's like it's not really
his hotel early life education business
today conflicts of interest I mean that
this is all here dude this is all what
usually you have on a rich guys
Wikipedia page all right let's get to
the questions because I got a [ __ ]
special to tape here tonight all right
what's the first question soccer
playoffs all right so I mentioned I was
saying how weird it is that they don't
have a playoff playoff in the Premier
League and how huge that would be so
evidently this person is going to set me
straight as to why they don't do it bill
they don't have us they don't have
soccer in playoffs they don't playoffs
in soccers with the person mentoring but
they happen to have various cup
competitions that add a different
dynamic to the mix when you think about
think about it it's extremely stupid to
have playoffs in the first place why
would the most consistent and best team
to top a table in any sport over the
duration of a season not get recognized
as the best team well easily well that's
easy well in our world you know you have
people just the way [ __ ] lines up who's
in your division you end up playing a
tougher schedule than somebody else you
know and it also depends like when you
play somebody if their best player was
hurt and then the other team comes to
play him and that guy's player is back
you know what I mean all of a sudden you
know this so it's just like you play a
whole season and somebody's one point
behind you you're the champion and
they're that I don't know
I like playoffs and then also playoffs
ads like this pressure was the team
that's supposed to win all of a sudden
feels this pressure and then they could
choke and you have great stories there's
plenty of reasons to have playoffs so I
don't think it's stupid it's extremely
stupid well then why do you have the
World Cup isn't that stupid isn't that a
giant [ __ ] planetary [ __ ] playoff
why isn't everybody just [ __ ] stay
home anyways I don't understand this
well that's a cup competition that's a
different thing so you're into playoffs
as long as it's a cup
it's extremely stupid I don't think it
is anyone hockey is the only sport where
I understand respect the league
structure because the Stanley Cup is
arguably the most difficult trophy to
win all right you're all over the map
here sir
you can maybe get away with half-assing
in the regular season to clinch playoffs
but you have a long way to go to hoist
the cup they actually have a playoff
format in the English Championship which
is the league right below the Premier
League first and second in the table
automatically advanced to the Premier
League well third to six have a two leg
matchup to get in a final for that third
promotion spot oh that's cool so that's
where your playoffs are it's very
exciting because there are millions of
millions of dollars on the line with
that final game playoff all right so now
you like playoffs also offside is when
the attacking player is passed the final
defender at the point the ball is played
if you didn't have this in place
players would just cherry-pick all game
and the beautiful game would be a [ __ ]
show rat fest come back to Niagara
Canada take care
I get that [ __ ] that you can't just hang
but my thing is is if somebody's going
to run past you
they're not just cherry-pick and hanging
down the other end of the field if
somebody's gonna run faster you and
they're faster you can just slow down
and make them offsides that's [ __ ]
stupid that guy's faster than you we
beat you that's my problem not saying
that you know you know look in hockey
they have an offsides line you got to
clear the [ __ ] zone when the puck
comes out but like if somebody blows
past you with the puck they don't have
to [ __ ] wait til you get into the
zone you know what I mean sorry I know
it sounds like I'm drinking I'm just
drinking a giant bottle of water glass
bottle fancy man as Jim Norton likes to
say all right well I get that sir I
don't think I actually think do you
actually enjoy playoffs but you also
enjoy the Premier League so now you have
to say
it's extremely stupid and of course
because you're from Canada you get it in
the hockey you understand those playoffs
all right sending food back all right
this is what I wanted to hear from
people how you go about it he says I'm a
28 year old male living amongst you and
all the other narcissistic transplant
[ __ ] that decided they were too good
for their hometowns and needed to move
to this coastal Eden that we call Los
Angeles and attempt to achieve a dream
of creating career doing what I love
parentheses creating / playing music
well sorry if you wanted to play music
for a living you know you probably would
eventually move to Los Angeles to get
more in the mix or Nashville don't you
move where the industry is at any rate
um I guess he's got to be joking that
that Los Angeles isn't Eden it's not an
Eden you had to steal water to try and
turn it into a [ __ ] evening it's a
[ __ ] show
that shouldn't be there but it is and
what we've done it with it is is amazing
I'm am I saying we now with Los Angeles
I've had been they don't line at any
rate being a musician I worked a number
of side gigs including waiting tables
I've waited tables at cheap joints as
well as fine dining establishments like
award-winning chef dudes I I think this
guy was being sarcastic about LA anyways
at any rate I think I can set you
straight on sending food back basically
and maybe obviously the chief of the
restaurant the riskier it is to send
your food back great point when I work
fine dining you're primarily in a
restaurant where the kitchen is actually
open to the public so setting food back
is handled in front of the clientele and
thus would never be subjected to being
[ __ ] with another great point that
being said as you go down in price
typically not always your kitchen is
getting a little little bit more hidden
your employees are probably making less
and on top of that they're probably
always again not always because I
realized some cheaper restaurants are
amazing quality etc not as passionate
about what they're doing in that case
your food will possibly get [ __ ] with
okay here's another person Bay Billy
sugar tits never worry about sending
food back with social media today any
decent restaurant would rather you tell
them then tell the world that a meal was
poor if a dick if a dick ed works in the
kitchen what if a dick
Edie like the name Edie if a dick Edie
works in the kitchen the [ __ ] oh
this person was texting and I guess
there was some sort of weird he hit the
capital thing in a space button if a
[ __ ] works in the kitchen
who's going to spit in your food you can
guarantee the kitchens a [ __ ] hole
anyways see you at Royal Albert Hall on
Monday wait a minute never worry about
sending food back and then you end it
with if a [ __ ] works in the kitchen
who's going to spit in your food you can
guarantee the kitchens a [ __ ] anyway
meaning it doesn't make a difference
because what's already in the food I
don't know about that all right it's not
making me feel better
all right formula e a Billy burnout you
mentioned on a recent podcast that the
sports low between football and the
start of Formula One March Madness NBA
players etc has you as you down have you
tried to watch formula e to fill the gap
I'm watching for the first time this
year and it's been great like at the
hiccups now this is the all electric
racing series it's real easy to get up
to date since the races are time to have
a maximum length of 45 minutes plus one
lap the first four races this season are
all up on YouTube and they're they're
carried live on Fox Fox Sports 2 in the
US there is no team or set of teams that
dominate like in Formula One and there's
been passing galore in every race all
right I like this including a photo
finish in the last race so it's not
about getting to the first corner and
block
for the rest of the race there are no
pit stops but the team still have to
strategize to conserve energy so they
don't run out of power sure the cars
don't go as fast but the competition
makes more more than makes up for it in
my opinion bonus is in the last two
races of the season
seasons will be held back-to-back days
in New York City in July oh [ __ ] I might
be in New York in July
cheers and go [ __ ] yourself well
eventually I feel like those cars will
be faster than the Formula one cars
because just looking at how regular cars
are in the street you know what I mean
like they can make like what a Tesla is
shaped like the fact that zero to 60 can
be to [ __ ] Lamborghini I would think
that if you applied that same [ __ ] to
like a race car and absolutely no wait
other than the battery all it comes down
to is it is if the battery is going to
be lighter than the [ __ ] engine and
then you don't have all that [ __ ]
under the car where air can get caught
because you can just have that smooth
[ __ ] thing like they do want anything
I don't know I would think that the e
cars are gonna get faster right I don't
know I do think it's funny that people
that are into gas combustion engines
will think it's funny that they can only
run them for 45 minutes and ignore the
fact that the gas combustion engines
also have to pull over and get gas you
know it's also not a limitless energy
source what you got to have is you got
to have solar power you have somebody
with a giant [ __ ] solar panel
duct-taped to their [ __ ] head all
right
and a giant magnifying glass above it
the driver dies every race but there's
no pit stops and can still go 500 miles
that's how I would do it all right baby
name you just get people on death row to
drive so then also they won't give a
[ __ ] you know if this space or not to go
into the corner
it'll be really [ __ ] exciting he had
death row inmates with a [ __ ]
satellite not a satellite a [ __ ] what
he done a stroke I just said it solar
panel on their head with a giant
magnifying glass all right
right before they get in the car there
eat they late their last meal whatever
it is you know a little bit of
haagen-dazs so [ __ ] turnip and some
[ __ ] chicken whatever the [ __ ] it is
they want you know and you get him in
there and that's it it's like all right
and here's the thing if you win whoever
wins doesn't get killed plate no you'd
already died oh they got it yeah somehow
like if you win it's like the Dirty
Dozen if you win then like they let you
back out on the street killing back on
the street the [ __ ] murders I know
it's got to be something you can do
I don't well we get to eat I don't have
it all worked out all right baby name
negotiation strategy bill my wife in our
and and I are having our first baby
congratulations a baby girl oh you hit
the lottery and we couldn't be happier
happier the only issue is picking her
name and negotiations are deadlocked
here's the negotiation positions all
right I'm going to tell you this before
I go any further all right never tell
your daughter about this all right
whatever her name is
that's her name if you lose or your wife
loses on the debate do not [ __ ] bring
that up to you kid whatever that name is
the name all right my wife's tasted
names could be best described as
somewhere between Hollywood diva and a
1960s flower child oh my god think names
like Apple and Moonbeam Layla like the
Eric Clapton song is her best idea to
date but it wouldn't be my first choice
know that songs too popular I don't know
Layla's not bad I don't know okay I
would like to get my grandmother's name
Fumiko an old Japanese name somewhere
that's got to be a middle name dude
anywhere my daughter's name she died
before I was born and would really mean
a lot to me and my side of the family to
get that even as a meal now that's a
male name too
my wife doesn't like the
named Fumiko specifically she doesn't
like the way it sounds and thinks it
sounds too close to the word humor which
you was a scholar of French no is the
verb to smoke as in to smoke no in
French no I knew a rocket was something
like that I am basically willing to
concede the first name to get Fumiko as
a middle name well that's cool because
if the kids like half Japanese I don't
have you guys a full Japanese that's
cool if he gets a little bit of that in
there and the name a lot of people do
that anyways he said but I haven't
gotten much headway in negotiation again
I am willing to concede that the first
name be something kind of weird to get
my grandmother's name which is
admittedly unusual but highly meaningful
that as the middle name I have two
questions all right first of all if your
wife is gonna go all hippy trippy dippy
and then you you know you can't be like
[ __ ] like wheatgrass shot Fumiko
Johnson you can't have that I wouldn't
think not man this is tough because I
have to question how did you and the
lovely Nia go about picking your
daughter's name what is my path to
getting my wife to agree to Fumiko
Fumiko as my daughter's middle name
I think I think you guys need to stop
thinking about yourselves and think
about your daughter okay as she's gonna
have to be this name somebody's gonna
have to say this name and she's gonna
have to be like yes present okay so I
would just say to my wife like listen
I'd I'm willing to concede Fumiko all
right but when she's not gonna have some
hippy trippy [ __ ] [ __ ] white
celebrity kid [ __ ] name can't have
that yeah you're not naming this kid
after an emotion or a [ __ ] fruit or
vegetable it's just a [ __ ] s it's
just a [ __ ] [ __ ] thing to do to
your kid
it's so [ __ ] self-involved and it's
so just like oh look at me look how
creative I am it's just like don't you
remember going to school don't remember
those those first brutal years if there
was anything even remotely different
about you you were gonna get the [ __ ]
kicked out of you it's gonna happen
anyways why help the other kids out why
the kids gonna hate the [ __ ] name
anyways so I would be thinking about the
kid I wouldn't be thinking about my own
family and all of that type of [ __ ] just
give the kid a [ __ ] cool name that
sounds good with your last name and just
let you kid be who they want to [ __ ]
be all right and don't force your
[ __ ] agenda on them from day one with
some [ __ ] up goddamn name that's my
two cents alright alright lady asked me
to not burp at the gym okay hey Bilbo
saggy Baggins I was at the gym the other
day in my building trying to get back in
shape for this summer as I've been a
booze bag getting through this [ __ ]
winter anyways I was on the elliptical
at a nice brisk pace
185 rpms Jesus Christ and was listening
to your podcast actually and there was
one other woman on a treadmill three
treadmills away walking at a slight
incline and I'm guessing a speed at 2.3
and reading a novel oh yeah that's not
working out
my family has acid reflux so sometimes
at the gym when I'm really pushing it
I would inherently lightly burp every
few minutes at about 25 minutes into my
session I hear something coming from my
headphones and this late 50s wish lady
is waving at me out of my periphery I
looked and over at her and moved my
earpiece away to hear her and she said
nicely could you please not burp anymore
it's distracting me well dude if your
[ __ ] belching while running 185 man
sounds like you're flying just run a rod
I mean what are you doing you're in
public anyway built the amount of rage I
was filled with for such an insane
request was unfathomable well how loud
were you burping you had your headphones
on she put up with it for 20 [ __ ]
minutes he said I thought about going to
apologize to her asking her name and
giving her a fake name for myself and
then telling the leasing office the
office what a [ __ ] this lady was what is
with you young people just wanting to
tell on each other did you want to make
a video of it and then [ __ ] upload it
I just thought you guys are all just
trying to get each other in trouble and
kicked out of things the [ __ ] rat
generation I refrain finish my workout
and continued on with my day my question
for you is 1 am I just being completely
am I just in just being completely
flabbergasted by a lady walking on a
treadmill reading a book telling me not
to burp when I have her ger D and 2 what
what have you done in that situation to
first of all you know how to [ __ ] does
she know that you have acid [ __ ]
reflux and stop acting like you have
leukemia you know what I mean this is
this right here this is what's wrong
with with what social media did to the
individual you're in a public gym you're
belching no one wants to listen to you
[ __ ] burping and you're a boozy fat
[ __ ] because of the winter I respect the
fact you're trying to lose the weight
you know maybe if you ate better you
wouldn't have these this [ __ ] wouldn't
[ __ ] wants to sit and listen to you burp
when he gives a [ __ ] she's over there
walking half a mile an hour at the book
that's her loss she's not really working
out but she waited for [ __ ] 20
minutes for you to belch it out of your
system and you didn't it's [ __ ] gross
no no I would take I need a pack of
[ __ ] Rolaids
and go for a walk around the block but I
mean you can't be like belching in
public and then try and turn around and
make yourself the victim because you got
acid reflux you know what if she was
really gassy and was just farting the
entire time you know Jesus okay I have
irritable bowel syndrome
well [ __ ] you know go drink some of
that pink [ __ ] and [ __ ] go for a walk
go come in here and close the goddamn
door yeah you're [ __ ] gassy [ __ ] I
don't know what to tell you I I'd say
yeah you're in the wrong there sir
yeah no one wants to go to the gym
listen do burping going 90 miles an hour
and a [ __ ] elliptical and I don't
care about your acid reflux and how it
afflicts you as a person I think you
need to take that into consideration you
know why don't you just go get one of
those TRX bands and just workout in the
house we can easily go for a walk you
know it's better for the environment all
the energy then an elliptical uses let's
go walk up a hill if you can [ __ ]
burp to your heart's content
then you're not bugging her and she can
sit there and [ __ ] slowly walk to her
grave
she reads the next Harry Potter [ __ ]
novel right does that work just don't
work for everybody
I hope it does alright I am gonna have
to pull up a little bit short here I
apologize I just have to I gotta tape
this [ __ ] thing tonight and then I'll
be back in the States might be a little
jet lag I know these last couple ones
I've been a little [ __ ] scatterbrain
and jet-lagged I've just been working a
little too hard but you know after
tonight I'm on the other side of it and
hopefully I'll go back to I'm not being
a scatterbrain I'm just a normal level
of scatterbrain ish [ __ ] that I say
alright that is it
go [ __ ] yourselves I'll check in on you
on Thursday and thank you from from the
bottom of my heart everybody that showed
up on this run through the UK I've been
having a great time
alright that is it I'll see you Thursday